"THE FIVE" ."
♪ ♪
THE GLOVES ARE COMING OFF,
PRESIDENT TRUMP LASHING OUT IN
HIS ON ONGOING FEUD WITH
NANCY PELOSI, THE HOUSE SPEAKER
REPORTEDLY TOLD LEADING
DEMOCRATS, SHE DOESN'T WANT
TRUMP IMPEACHED, SHE WANTS TO
SEE HIM IN PRISON.
>> SHE HAS A DISASTER, LET HER
DO WHAT SHE WANTS.
I THINK THEY ARE IN BIG TROUBLE,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE KIND OF
CRIMES THAT WERE COMMITTED, I
DON'T NEED ANY MORE EVIDENCE AND
WHAT I'M HEARING, THERE'S A LOT
OF EVIDENCE COMING IN.
I'VE TRIED TO BE NICE TO HER
BECAUSE I WOULD'VE LIKED TO OF
GOTTEN SOME DEALS DONE.
SHE IS INCAPABLE OF DOING DEALS,
SHE IS OUR NASTY, VINDICTIVE,
HORRIBLE PERSON.
THE MUELLER REPORT CAME OUT, IT
WAS A DISASTER FOR THEM.
A HORRIBLE, NASTY, VICIOUS
STATEMENT WHILE I'M OVERSEAS.
IF I MADE A STATEMENT OVER
ANYBODY, WHY WOULD HE DO THAT
WHEN HE'S OVERSEAS?
SHE HAS A TERRIBLE PERSON AND I
WILL TELL YOU, HER NAME IS
NERVOUS NANCY BECAUSE SHE HAS A
NERVOUS WRECK.
>> Juan: JESSE, TODAY, THE
PRESIDENT FOLLOWED UP WITH A
TWEET, I THINK WE HAVE IT HERE,
IN WHICH HE TALKS ABOUT NOT
IMPEACHMENT BUT AGAIN, GOING TO
JAIL.
I'M THINKING TO MYSELF, HE SAYS
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE TO JUSTIFY
HAVING NANCY PELOSI MAKE SUCH A
STATEMENT BUT I'M THINKING, IF
GOING TO JAIL ALL IS ON HIS
MIND, IS HE SCARED?
>> Jesse: TRUMP LOOKS NERVOUS,
DOESN'T HE?
YOU REALLY THINK HE THINKS HE'S
GOING TO JAIL?
HE IS NOT GOING TO JAIL AND
NERVOUS NANCY IS A TOP-FIVE
NICKNAME AND THAT'S GOING TO
STICK.
I WANT TO ADDRESS THE ELEPHANT
IN A ROOM, GREG IS IN A PANIC.
HE JUST FOUND OUT IT'S IN THE
CITY AND THIS MAN IS SWEATING
BULLETS, HE'S GOING TO RECORD IT
IN CASE SOMEONE TRIES TO
SABOTAGE IT FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES.
THE MAN IS PARANOID.
I DON'T THINK IS GOING TO MAKE
IT TO THE SHOW.
>> Greg: I'M ANXIOUS BECAUSE
SOMEBODY IN MY EAR, PRODUCER
SAID THE PROMPTER OPERATOR WAS
AT THIS LOCATION.
AT 4:59, BEFORE THE SHOW STARTE
STARTED.
>> Juan: DID YOU PASS YOUR
DRIVING TEST?
>> Katie: MY MOTHER MADE ME
LEARN TO DRY A STICK SHIFT IN
OUR TRUCKER'S LOT.
>> Juan: YOU DON'T THINK HE'S
WORRIED ABOUT GOING TO JAIL?
>> Jesse: NO, JUAN, HE IS NOT
GOING TO JAIL.
>> Juan: A LOOK AT THE
PRESIDENT THERE, I'M THINKING,
DANA WORKS FOR THE WHITE HOUSE,
DANA UNDERSTANDS THE POWER OF
THE OFFICE.
HE'S GOING ON ATTACKING --
>> Dana: HE WAS ASKED
QUESTIONS AND WHEN HE IS ASKED
QUESTIONS, HE ANSWERS THEM.
HE COULD'VE SAID, COME BACK THIS
WEEK WHEN I'M BACK AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, WE CAN TALK ABOUT
ALL OF THIS.
NANCY PELOSI IS THERE AS WELL,
"I'M NOT GOING TO DO THAT
OVERSEAS."
I DON'T THINK SHE WAS TOO UPSET
THAT THE ARTICLE WAS PRINTED
BACK HOME SAYING THAT SHE AS A
DEMOCRATIC MEETING SAID SHE
WOULD RATHER SEE HIM IMPRISONED
BECAUSE IT MADE HER LOOK TOUGH.
SHE THINKS IT RATTLES HIM.
HE WANTS TO COUNTERPUNCH AND --
IT COULD BE ON TWITTER.
THIS IS A FEUD THAT IS GOING TO
GO ON FOREVER.
I FEEL LIKE EVERY HOUR THERE IS
SOMETHING ELSE.
LAST HOUR WE FOUND OUT THAT
GROUPS OR WHO WORKED AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHO WAS DEMOT
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHO WAS DEMOD
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHO WAS DEMO,
BEFORE HE LEFT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HE WAS GIVEN
$48,000 IN BONUS MONEY.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
>> Jesse: DANA, BRINGING THE
HEAT.
>> Dana: I AM JUST SAYING,
THERE IS SOMETHING EVERY DAY YOU
CAN PICK APART.
THE OTHER THING IS U.S. ATTORNEY
JOHN DURHAM IS WORKING ON THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE
INVESTIGATOR, APPARENTLY IT WAS
SAID TO OUR OWN KEVIN HARRIS
THAT HE'S ASKING ALL THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS BUT
IT'S ENOUGH TO GET THE STORY
GOING FOR ANOTHER THREE DAYS
UNTIL YOU HAVE JOHN DEAN
TESTIFYING IN FRONT OF THE HOUSE
ON MONDAY.
>> Juan: FORGET THE JAIL STUFF
FOR A SECOND, THE PRESIDENT SAYS
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE, HE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND IT AND YET
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TODAY IS
PRINTING AN ARTICLE IN WHICH IT
SAYS, HERE'S WHAT ARTICLES UNDER
IMPEACHMENT MIGHT LOOK LIKE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> Greg: THE TIMES OP-ED HAS
SHOWED YOU HOW THE MEDIA HAS
ESSENTIALLY BECOME BATHHOUSE.
THE TWITTER ACTIVISTS ARE
TWEETING TO GET THE ATTENTION OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THE REST OF THE WORLD GOES ON.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HISTORICAL
UNEMPLOYMENT, YOU SEE PROGRESS
ON VARIOUS FRONTS, YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT TARIFFS, TRADE, JOBS, THE
ECONOMY.
AS OPPOSED TO WORDS BUT THE
TIMES CAN'T LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE
IT DESTROYS THEIR ENTIRE
NARRATIVE.
CAN I TALK ABOUT NERVOUS NANCY?
IT IS A GREAT NICKNAME BECAUSE
YOU CAN USE IT ON ANYBODY.
NERVOUS NANCY NOW REPLACES
NERVOUS NELLY.
YOU ARE TOO YOUNG TO KNOW
>> Dana: NEGATIVE NANCY.
>> Greg: I AM A NERVOUS NANCY.
I THINK THERE WAS A
JUXTAPOSITION THERE WITH THE
ROWS AND ROWS OF THE DEAD AND
THIS IS A WEEK WHEN WE ARE
HONORING THOSE PEOPLE BUT FROM
WHEN YOU ARE BEING INTERVIEWED,
YOU DON'T -- YOU AREN'T THINKING
ABOUT WHAT'S BEHIND YOU MOST OF
THE TIME WHEN YOU ARE BEING
INTERVIEWED.
I THINK THE JUXTAPOSITION IS
INTERESTING BECAUSE BACK IN THAT
TIME THEY WERE DODGING GRENADES
BEING HURLED AT THEM AND HERE
IT'S JUST INSULTS.
MAYBE THE JUXTAPOSITION,
IRONICALLY, TALKS ABOUT HOW WE
ARE IN A LUCKY, BETTER TIME
BECAUSE OF THOSE ROWS AND ROWS
OF DEAD BEHIND HIM.
I DON'T KNOW, IT'S KIND OF AN
INTERESTING THING AND AN ODD
PLACE TO HAVE AN INTERVIEW.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT IT WAS ME
BEING SENSITIVE, ROBERT MUELLER
IS A FORMER MARINE, VIETNAM
VETERAN, IS THIS THE PLACE?
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK THERE
SHOULD BE ANY INTERVIEWS THERE,
THAT'S HOW I FEEL.
>> Juan: IS THE PRESIDENT
COMES HOME HE'S GOING TO FACE A
LOT OF ISSUES, SOME UNCERTAIN
ECONOMIC NUMBERS, LOWER INTEREST
RATES, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
OF COURSE HE'S GOT THE BATTLE
WITH REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE
OVER THE USE OF TARIFFS, ON THE
IMMIGRATION ISSUE.
>> Katie: IN TERMS OF WORKING
WITH NANCY PELOSI ON THINGS LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE, I THINK
DEMOCRATS ARE MISSING A BIG
OPPORTUNITY HERE.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT INTO
THE OVAL OFFICE, HE WASN'T A
HARD PARTISAN, HE WAS AN
INDEPENDENT RUN ON REPUBLICAN
TICKET.
AND HE'S DONATED TO DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS FOR ALL KINDS OF
CAUSES, HE'S BEEN OPEN ABOUT THE
FACT THAT HE WANTED TO DO
INFRASTRUCTURE DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.
THERE ARE THINGS DEMOCRATS COULD
WORK WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP ON TO
REGAIN A LOT OF THE BLUE-COLLAR
WORKERS.
THAT PEOPLE LIKE JOE BIDEN ARE
TRYING TO REGAIN BUT BECAUSE OF
THIS CONSTANT FEUD THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING.
I THINK DEMOCRATS ARE MISSING
THEIR CHANCE TO GET A LOT OF
THINGS DONE OR AT LEAST TALK
ABOUT WHY IT'S IMPORTANT.
ONE MORE THING ON NANCY PELOSI,
SHE MADE THIS COMMENT, THE
PRESENT IS ASKED ABOUT IT, NOT
ALLOWED TO RESPOND TO BECAUSE
HE'S OVERSEAS, I STILL DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE DYNAMIC OF THESE
ACCUSED OF SOMETHING AND WHEN HE
RESPONDS, HE'S THE ONE WHO'S IN
THE WRONG.
GOT HE'S NOT ALLOWED TO RESPOND
TO ALLEGATIONS OR ACCUSATIONS
ANYMORE?
>> Jesse: YOU CAN ARGUE THAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN CLASSIER
IN REGARDS TO HIS TREATMENT OF
NANCY PELOSI.
HE CAME IN AND HAD VERY NICE
THINGS TO SAY ABOUT NANCY AND
CHUCK AND TOLD ME WHEN I
INTERVIEWED HIM, HE'S LOOKING
FORWARD TO NEGOTIATING WITH THEM
AND THINKS THEY'RE GREAT PEOPLE
AND HE TRIED TO DO THAT SEVERAL
TIMES, HE'S MET WITH THEM AND
TRY TO BRING THEM ON BOARD ON
BIPARTISAN ISSUES LIKE
RENEGOTIATING NAFTA OR FIXING
THE IMMIGRATION CRISIS BUT TIME
AND TIME AGAIN, HE'S BEEN
SABOTAGED BY NANCY AND THEN SHE
SAYS DIRTY, NASTY THINGS JUST TO
ASSUAGE HER CAUCUS BECAUSE SHE'S
LOST CONTROL.
AND I THINK IT LOOKS LIKE HE'S
HAD IT.
>> Katie: IF YOU LOOK AT THE
WAY CHUCK SCHUMER REACTS AND THE
WAY NANCY PELOSI REACTS,
CHUCK SCHUMER IS MUCH MORE
RESERVED WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT
HE SAYING ABOUT THE PRESIDENT,
WHEREAS NANCY PELOSI IS CATERING
TO THE FAR LEFT OF HER PARTY